[Music]
bad parenting news Oh submitted by a
home girl from paramount Wood I'm not
from there I have friends from there
does that count yeah I know where it's
at does that count Paramount Pictures
actually is it from Paramount I always
thought that one oh a little a paramount
means it's super important oh yeah you
the father of a missing three year old
girl left her outside as punishment
because she wouldn't drink her milk is
this considered bad panting OH regular
agent Randy
what if she's lactose intolerant why
would she want to drink milk we should
have tummy area Korea's very Korean so I
mean like did you yeah all the time like
if I caught three like three that's too
old too but you know it would usually be
the backyard my mom wouldn't know it was
the front door he did that front yard
too my mom told me the story where my
brother he was like saying he was gonna
run away I think you were supposed to
clean up his dishes I can't recall right
now but he was I you supposed to clean
up your dishes or or whatever and he
goes no I don't want to my mom's like
I'm warning you and he just kind of like
dinners okay he was fine I'm gonna leave
he says his little look colorful
backpack start putting his favorite toys
it my home list of up she goes oh that
stuff is mine she stretched my brother
butt-naked in the middle of winter
I kicks about something and she said
that he was so stubborn like for the
first like I forgot how many Amish time
passed he didn't make a single [ __ ]
noise and then finally he just starts
crying out of note but my mom's stricken
butt-ass naked I kicked him out the
front what she like what a tough boy she
does I do that to him it made her more
mad because she was like oh he won't
break until like something bad happens
so until you started freezing his ass
I'll be starting to write man I remember
as soon as my mom would shut the door I
would start banging like I'm never gonna
get back in I was gonna be left outside
[ __ ] game over Sharon ingredient well
well I was way off Hispanic or Filipino
so this little girl she's from
Richardson Texas which is a suburb of
Dallas and according to her father
around 3:00 a.m. she would refuse to
drink her milk
yeah why isn't she asleep and I'll
explain in a second and so as a
punishment he sent her out to the back
yard to stand near a large tree and then
he says 15 minutes later she went back
to check on her and that's what she was
missing but instead of calling the cops
then and there he ends up going inside
his home does some laundry tells the
wife hey the girls missing and they wait
until after 8 o'clock a.m. to call the
police because they just bury that she
was gonna come back that's weird and he
the father also mentioned many years old
well show GPS her way back home but what
if chupacabra got her the father also
mentioned that he did know that there
were there was a coyote activity in that
area and he didn't care until 8:00 in
the morning
exactly he confessed to all this
information so yeah that's what he was
telling the clock he doesn't have a
fence in his backyard it was like an
alley type of thing I'm not sure exactly
what she found alive he's a serial
killer so she's still missing as far as
I know what the [ __ ] this is the father
what she get abducted so that's what
they're thinking there's a Mexican post
at 3 a.m. though she probably walked
away a neighbor said that this couple
had been struggling to have a kid for a
long time they finally had a kid who was
now 4 years old and then they're saying
that they felt that since God gave him
that baby as a miracle baby that they
could help another little one that
doesn't have a family so they went to
India they adopted Sharon and when they
adopted her she was really malnourished
she has developmental issues that and
limited communications no they're just
like really that makes sense what she
wouldn't want to drink her milk I don't
know what milk was yeah and then he's
saying like they would feed her at all
hours of the day just to get her to get
nourished again you should have federer
mango lassi mmm like mango lassi yeah
people are devout Christians that means
nothing to me
devout Christians and the church people
they went over to the house and they
were just praying and stuff but now
apparently their reports coming out
saying that these parents are no longer
cooperating with the police which is
[ __ ] fishy right so we're like what
the hell's happening
so the that four-year-old that they have
is now in the custody of a family friend
oh they found the kids no no they had
the biological couldn't have one and
then finally they had one that kids four
and then they adopted kind of extreme
for sending the kid out into a backyard
with a bunch of coyotes at 3:00 a.m. and
developmental issues yeah that's kind of
like your dad would you drink your milk
outside it sounds like they're at wit's
end
hmm and then they were like we can't
deal with this kid anymore let's kill
the kid that's what they were thinking
maybe that's killed a kid well it hasn't
been reported yet that the parents are
suspects but they are saying that the
mom gave a different account to the
police saying that her daughter was
asleep during the time that she went
missing but the father is saying no I
sent her outside and then I went inside
and did laundry
is it fenced off their backyard they
don't specify that but that's okay I
mean that still doesn't like debunk her
story because if he was setting her
outside she wouldn't know yeah but it
was still like now and also both parents
are working with different attorneys
they killed her you think sounds too
[ __ ] fishy to me that is so sad
because they're not worried they're not
like oh she's missing let me call the
police he goes back inside like I don't
get it
that's true a responsible parent if you
send them outside you would watch them
you would still peek through the blinds
to make sure that they're suffering and
if they keep suffering like okay good
but if they're out there [ __ ] making
sandcastles you go out there and you
[ __ ] pour cold water on him or
something yeah so the father was
arrested and charged with child
endangerment but now he's out on bail
and he has like a monitor bracelet or
ink banquet or the house arrest bracelet
yeah so now he has that and they're just
still looking for the little girl
question now that you two are parents to
do these stories affect you differently
enough or is it absolutely No so before
you were cold
before you were cold-hearted but now you
have a child you feel that you grew a
heart no I just couldn't relate like the
way you guys probably can't relate like
you you obviously feel bad right for
this child
oh yeah yeah and with children they
don't you don't understand a lot of
things they're very helpless right but
now when it's your own you're just like
oh my god you put your kid and that's a
trick that's why you always there so do
you feel like I know what they're going
through sometimes my kid stresses me out
I want to I'm not there yet maybe TIFF
knows no I think what she's saying is
like when things like this happened to
other kids you immediately put your kid
in that position and you think of like
holy [ __ ] what if though like yeah I
don't ever do that's crazy I don't think
I don't put my normal I'm not allowed to
speak you can but then that's why you're
you're deemed a pedo weirdo because you
say weird [ __ ] have you ever got so
angry at your child what are you
thinking I'm just gonna drop this [ __ ]
off somewhere mm-hmm okay
I really wow you're so patient no I
thought like because my parents have
told me that directly yeah me too me too
me it's not like stuff they they kept
inside for for like 30 years they've
told me to my face
Mike was going through his temper
tantrums around like three or four where
I remember was one time I was in the
grocery store and he just would not stop
crying and I wasn't there alone like I
couldn't just drive off I went with
someone else
duct tape and then I just was outside
and I was just closing and I was sobbing
myself cuz I'm like [ __ ] what do i do I
don't know what to do oh my god this
kids crave driving me crazy with the
help what did you try that's like the
furthest I think in that moment I did
feel like [ __ ] I give up I don't know
what to do I can't be your mother
I suck look at my kid he's just crying
and crying crying because you also
didn't have that male support in your
life at the other time cuz and I was
like that no how the hell does that he
was 328 no twenty yeah 20 that's when
you need the guy to come in and beat the
[ __ ] kids ass yup
the guy comes in and like hey listen I
know that you're hurting but you're
gonna be a lot more pain if you keep
crying I can't wait to say that phrase
cuz it's so no but that's why we can't
reason yeah we don't know how to raise
it I think like I'll raise it up to a
certain extent but I still want to say
the lines that my
said to me to my kid famous one-liners
it helped you it did but those I don't
think so it's alive I see you don't
think about that though look at that it
helps you that's how you break all your
phones every time you get pissed no but
anyway come on that lies so I think
David's a pretty a human being yeah
you're also [ __ ] up yeah thank you see
I'm a great to be parents wait don't say
that be wary in some areas pregnant oh
she's not pregnant but yeah I would like
to say those lines though cuz they're
very very poetic it's like [ __ ]
WordArt
yes I found you in a dumpster makes me
feel great ya know think about that it's
like why did they all see the same thing
like that it's not that creative
because it's all it's all the same [ __ ]
yeah it's across every single Asian
country it's like in some old ancient
scroll word I just wrote it you just say
you're not my son
yeah I mean the only life that I can
remember that I've told Isaac is just
like the innocent ones us about Santa
and the Tooth Fairy well I think I've
ever made up things like that I never
believed in the tooth fairy or Santa
Claus I did I mean I I believed in them
my parents did a good job shielding me
in making a magical world my mom did
that on accident with my with my nephews
this weekend she was telling us what she
would do with us in front of them and
I'm like oh I'm like pathetic loss is
real oh she was and she caught herself
she's like yup it is I was just holding
the present for him I got in trouble in
kindergarten because I told another kid
that he was dumb for the Santa Claus
thing Jen you've always been David yeah
because I did it well my parents didn't
teach me about it that's at a Korean
[ __ ] thing you know so they're like
oh this guy comes here and he comes down
a chimney I might dance we're like we
pay for the [ __ ] [ __ ] your white man
yeah really was you joke but that's
seriously what it is aren't you a
Christian or something don't you Santa
hasn't is not Christian like generally
Christians also believe in Santa Clara
or like they practice that tradition of
Christmas Christmas is all about
Christmas
there's a whole different thing yes
Anna's not Christian it's just American
right or European it's like European of
Germanic or something like that ripping
out over the Starbucks cups cuz it was
like no more like Christ in a I don't
know I don't know what that [ __ ]
stupid but once again I was Korean
Christian too so that's different you
know a lot like religious stuff - it's
like culturally tied as well like if you
go to a Korean church Christian Church
it's very Korean Christian vs. white
Christian yes like culture and religion
starts to mix together since okay from
your pastors Mackey here in there 100% I
remember when I found out that Santa
wasn't real and it was just parents
giving you gifts like in the first grade
or something I felt like I had to be a
whistleblower so in my class I was like
teacher I have something to say and then
I told it once and it's not real the
parents do it and they were so mad at me
and then all the kids were like what and
I was like I had to be honest if Jesus
said so I was so conflicted because
you're taught not to lie and you have to
do you have to be honest and at the same
time something that was [ __ ] so lying
was happening on Christmas yeah even the
Tooth Fairy concept right you know how
you they would put that dirty ass tooth
pillow never did that my mom would just
rip it out my [ __ ] face and then give
me money it wasn't like wait for the
Tooth Fairy to come
it was more like here's a dollar you
know so I would just wait what was it
one of the money then was he didn't
crying did a good job
oh so I didn't know that that other like
people got money because the Tooth Fairy
would come and give them money
my mom rip up my all my teeth like to be
rich I I didn't believe in Santa but I
did believe in the tooth fairy
my mom always gave me money and I would
like set up tests cuz of my bed was next
to the window so I was like this time
I'm gonna lock the window yeah lock the
window and I'd go to sleep and I wake up
money oh [ __ ] the Tooth Fairy is real
but Santa Claus although you guys are so
stupid he carefully being Santa I wish I
had those moments though men like I
never got to have that but you're not
gonna let your kids have anything oh no
Muriel said that she like if we have
kids that they're definitely gonna
believe like yea Mario's [ __ ]
Disneyland yeah so I'm she still
believes in that [ __ ] yeah when we go to
Disneyland what I view at Disneyland is
different from from her when I see I see
grey building
worn out blue worn out pink Tinkerbell
comes to welcome that's what she sees
she doesn't need ya she got her
imagination in Mickey Mouse come over
hey thanks for watching guys and those
are our thoughts what are your thoughts
don't forget to comment below we want to
know what you guys are thinking but
don't write anything that will make it
sad or make us mad because after all
we're just kidding news and we're a very
happy channel for the last video click
up here
[Music]